50% of men aged 18 to 24 have never
approached a woman in person in their
life and uh like even higher percentage
18 to 30 haven't approached woman in the
last year is this Downstream from me
too I have a certainly Weir take on this
which is that actually the thing you
hear about as sort of the thing that Gen
X people talk about of going up to
someone in a bar and this being a way of
striking out relationships I think that
was a very brief period of History sort
of post-sexual Revolution but pre-
internet where that was considered
normal um and I'm slightly too young to
have ever actually experienced
that the normal way actually that people
start relationships in the vast majority
of cultures is to be
like is like semi- arranged marriage
right like not the fool you've never met
this person before you know 13year olds
whatever getting betrayed like not like
that but the sort of you're introduced
by family members mutual friends you're
known in the community you go to the
same church whatever it is and then your
both of your families like consent to
the marriage
and it works out okay but that but the
expectation isn't like the expectation
of marriage up until relatively recently
was that you would have an economic
relationship a you know and a
reproductive relationship but you
weren't best friends mhm and actually I
don't think I don't think husbands and
wives used to talk to each other as much
as they do now I think people used to
have much more homosocial kind of lives
you'd hang out with other men you'd hang
out with other women you wouldn't
necessarily hang out a lot with the
opposite sex including your spouse um so
this idea that like they going up to a
person in the bar is like the normal and
natural way of starting relationships I
don't think is historically accurate
that's interesting so the male
version felt fear of approach anxiety
which every guy listening is aware of
apart from the Psychopaths right there
is a girl that I find attractive that I
either know or don't know or partly know
or whatever yeah hi how are you nice to
meet you is kind of like a miniature war
that you have to go to and the felt
sense of palpable fear is just ripping
you apart
inside that isn't or the modern aversion
to that isn't some novel new problem it
was a in your opinion here a bar that
kind of never really needed to be gotten
over in the first place in some regards
because you had seen each other at
church for ages or her father owned the
farm next to your father's land and you
guys had know blah blah blah like yeah
yeah people have much more kind of
static social lives so yeah just
approaching some
stranger and ending up getting married
to her is not I had this uh I had this
conversation with a guy called mads
lasson who is a mating ideology
researcher I'll send it to you it's
phenomenal and he talks about
this all of the different uh
Arrangements that people went through
and the uh romantic to the confluent
which is what we've moved through most
recently has left us with a really
interesting vestage which is previously
it was they own the the farm next door
it was almost like a tactical marriage
between the two of you and then no no no
no you're supposed to you guys are
supposed to be together forever you know
there is supposed to be deeper meaning
instantiated in this but then as soon as
you have the sexual Revolution you have
Confluence so for as long as you can
benefit me and I can benefit you I think
even Mia Khalifa who obviously Paragon
of sexual virtue uh said on a recent
interview that um people think that
marriage is some sacred thing it's not
it's just a piece of paper and if this
person isn't helping you grow it's time
to move on um so they just the confluent
like uh ideology there helping you grow
front center you need to be helping them
grow yeah I'm not sure yeah helping you
prepare for your next porn scene I don't
know whatever she meant um so you have
this really interesting thing which is
that both the two most recent cultures
have kind of got like conceptual inertia
inside of our heads that we have this
sense and we were kind of told and maybe
some people think that it's true that
you're supposed to find a person who
fulfills who is your Confidant your best
friend your the sexual Paramore your the
co-owner of your children and the
household and all the rest of the things
yeah and yet modern culture is this more
Confluence thing which is they're
supposed to benefit you and help you
grow and these two things kind of bounce
off against each other and then you know
if we look back ancestrally at what
we're predisposed for it's [__]
neither of those two right like you can
say what you want about the truthfulness
or utility of both of those it wasn't
that and it seems Seems like serial
monogamy as what we built for some
combination of Po polygyny and serial
monogamy uh and all of these the
existing base rate of what we are plus
the two most recent cultures are just
like like the Bermuda Triangle of mating
ideologies inside of our mind yeah
there's this book called the um the All
or Nothing marriage which is about sort
of yes this modern conception of
marriage
where where exactly this you put so much
expectation on your spouse that they
will be
you know you will be perfectly sexually
compatible perfectly like
conversationally compatible per you know
everything everything is perfect and
obviously for loads of people that isn't
going to be true and that's not going to
be true for 60 years or whatever that
you might be together um and so you end
up with this All or Nothing thing that
like some people have absolutely
fabulous marriages and some people just
they can't possibly take this strain and
so they collabs and the authors compare
it to um maso's hierarchy of needs where
like if you're in a position if you're
you're in a situation of economic
subsistance you basically just see your
spouse as like your economic partner
with whom you have children but your
expectations are not that high and then
you reach the point where you're so
affluent right in contempary culture
where you kind of regard marriage as yes
as fulfilling all of these like esoteric
psychological needs which is just not
reasonable so I honestly this again Mary
Harrington endless quotable she has this
uh this this this saying that we should
abolish big romance yeah that the idea
of having these incredible like romantic
expectations of your spouse is just
pretty much setting yourself up fail one
woman meme machine isn't she she really
is um what was your thing it was you
that reminded me of a story that I'd
forgotten from my childhood about uh
ladies dropping
handkerchiefs oh right as a way of like
demonstrating interest yeah so I had
this thing with me and David bus came up
with this solution uh around women
cultivating receptiveness if they want
to improve their dating Prospect now in
a post me too world where we're worried
about uh women's safety especially
sexually this is something that is kind
of difficult to say but again if you
want to work within the confines of how
reality is not how you want it to be I
think that women cultivating
receptiveness accounts for the male
approach anxiety problem right that you
know
a a slightly lingering a longer
lingering eye than you think or like you
know smiling at somebody as opposed to
doing the uh why men love [__] treat
him mean keep him Keen kind of approach
men are going to be so bad at receiving
those signals though don't you think
have you ever heard that uh the average
man of 130 IQ has the like emotional
social receptivity of a woman with 70
IQ like the difference this is what my
husband you're saying we're actually
socially [__] yeah my my husband and
I my husband calls me a witch because I
can like I'll be able to like sense
there's something off you are
particularly witchy today with the with
the olive as well yeah I think it's just
women I think we are just witchy witchy
that's why you were burned at the Stak
BR back you can just like sense that
something I don't know facial
expressions whatever something which
most men are just oblivious too with
with some exceptions clearly okay so
yeah well let's take that as the again
the thermodynamics of the situation that
men are uh their EQ is 50% of what a
woman's is essentially um if that is the
case leaning in even further to not
being receptive is going to make said
blinked man even less capable of
understanding that maybe you're
interested oh yeah yeah right so I just
think
that again another Confluence of the
hydra's head of lots of stuff that's
going on the multifactorial problem uh
women are maybe being a little bit more
more masculine working in more masculine
environments thinking they need to be
more disagreeable to be more effective
at work concerned about their own safety
uh generally skeptical of of men that
come up to them strange men that come up
to them in a bar which has led to
absolutely less receptivity from women
and it's like look if you are
complaining like where are all of the
Good Men at look around a little bit if
you can when you're at your CrossFit
class or you're doing yoga or you're
doing whatever and if someone if some
guy comes up to you and asks some
awkward clunky question but he's kind of
cute like don't just presume that he's
asking the question like use the witch
Clairvoyance right tap into the astral
realm or whatever it is that you do and
think oh yeah have you heard of the the
male overperception and the female under
perception bias is this with sexual
interest correct yeah yeah that's in
David David bus's book that men uh
overestimate the degree of interest that
women have to them and women
underestimate which is largely why you
have awkward passes by uh male
co-workers and and stuff well what do
you mean like her eyes and you saw the
way that she looked at me every time we
went to the copy machine or whatever and
you know alcohol exaggerates that does
it really yeah so men are more likely to
falsely perceive sexual interest when
they're drunk fantastic which again just
makes so much sense of all the you know
like were you um you know that there was
like me too but for schools in the UK a
few years ago it was called everyone's
invited it was like a website that some
some girls set up to to describe like
bad sexual experiences that they'd had
with um what they in school well not
also not normally in school this was the
thing so it ended up being a big um
headache for teachers and head teachers
because parents were obviously really
upset understandably um and they said
you know you should be teaching consent
workshops in schools you should doing
all these things and the teachers are
like this isn't happening in school very
rarely is this happening in school this
is normally happening happening Friday
night at some house party the par
parents aren't there everyone's
drunk and like it's kind of the parents
responsibility honestly to stop that
step yeah and it's like look you've got
horny young men raised on porn plus
alcohol young women often giving
confusing signals I mean one of the
things that like teenage girls just
don't understand bless them is like if
you if you say dress in revealing
clothes because you want to attract a
particular
man that the blast radius of that signal
you
yeah like I was I was getting a train
recently in London and there was a
school girl who was probably like 16 who
was walking ahead of me and she was
going up the
stairs and she was wearing such a short
skirt going to school that I could see
absolutely everything and I like I
almost jogged after her just to say like
you're lucky it was me who was walking
behind you and I know that you're doing
this
because you want to feel I like there is
a kind of thrill of feeling sexy that
young women experienced for the first
time and they have no
idea how potent and dangerous that that
tool is so you know you do it because
there's like a particular guy who gets
the same train as you who you want to
catch his eye or whatever fine but like
I could have been a creepy bloke and
this is why I think parents have to
be banning their daughters from leaving
the house looking like that basically
because they have no idea like teenage
girls are just I mean Teena you know
teenagers are dumb the the sort of me
too conversation around victim blaming
and and stuff is such a deep hole when
you get into it to talk about should
things be this way no are things this
way yes do you want to play within the
confines of the thermodynamics of this
particular system well you probably
should right and to thread that needle
especially
because I I often think about this um
Douglas Murray once taught me that it
doesn't really matter who makes the best
logical argument in a debate if you
manage to get two or three three big
laughs you win yes it's true and it's
almost it's all Vibes yep it's Just Vibe
you're a Vibe architect right and the
problem with this discussion if you have
somebody who is very anti- this and is
saying that's victim blaming you
absolutely you saying that you're giving
men a pass you're saying that women
should be fearful of what they should
wear and it's like that particular
talking point is
so empathetically robust in its
signaling that it almost always wins
yeah because the
most obviously caring argument upfront
that sounds like the one that sounds
right that sounds like the one that you
will get the most support for on
Twitter it's so tough to it's like right
yeah yeah no I don't
disagree but look at the outcomes that
we get from this one of the things that
um progressives really have on their
side rhetorically is that if if you're
if you're a conservative who's saying
look actually you know there was a line
that one of my readers sent me from a
from all places it was a book about um
uh making wine and the line was um
Traditions or experiments that
worked you can say that when you're
talking about wine making and it's not
too like politically explosive but you
can obviously apply that to to to
social experiments that work exactly but
what you end up if you're trying to make
argument and if you're and if you're you
know proposing anything remotely
conservative is that you have
to you end up having to defend other
cultures or cultures of the past so
you'll say look actually you know there
was a lot to be said for the sort of
slightly arranged marriage there's a lot
to be said for teenage girls being
encouraged to dress more modestly
whatever and people say oh what so
you're saying that you support domestic
violence you're saying that you support
you know Cher and imperialism and like
everything that might have happened
during the era that you're talking about
and you have to say no no I don't I mean
you just end up at them back foot
whereas if you're a progressive you can
say I can see this Vision you know like
in the future we'll have this amazing
Society where everything's great and the
fact that this is this has never
happened and is never likely to happen
means that you never you're never in the
position of having to defend anything
unfortunate you never have to talk about
tradeoffs I think that like
acknowledging the existence of
trade-offs is a fundamentally
conservative trait yeah Thomas Soul
there are no Solutions only trade-offs
yeah it's really painful but it's true
unfortunately in other news this episode
is brought to you by cozy Earth we sleep
onethird of Our Lives do not spend 33%
of your life in anything other than
unbeatably comfortable sheets getting a
good night's sleep is the Ultimate Game
Changer and the sheets that you have are
a massive determinant of just how
comfortable you feel cozy Earth has the
most premium bedding and loungewear that
I've ever found they're made from super
soft Visos from highly sustainable
bamboo temperature regulating so you
will sleep comfortably all year round
and an enhanced weave quality that won't
pill so it's higher quality will last
longer and you will have a more
comfortable night's sleep and wake up
feeling more rested and revitalized plus
there is a 10-year warranty on all of
their products that's how confident they
are that they're going to last but don't
just take my word for it Oprah has
chosen cozy Earth as one of her favorite
things for 5 years in a row now you can
get an exclusive 35% discount sitewide
on everything by going to Cozy earth.com
slod wisdom and using the code modern
wisdom 35 a checkout cozy earth.com /od
wisdom and modern wisdom a checkout
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that clip with Louise then press
here for the ful length 2hour long
podcast go
on give it a
press